So last week we talked about morality and the fact that morality points to God,
gives us some evidence for the fact that a divine creator actually exists.
Now for these next couple of units you might be thinking, why are we talking about
beauty, agency, and story?
Now these next few lessons are not as difficult as what we've tackled in the last
few, last couple of months, but don't gloss over these.
Don't just kind of fly through them like they're no big deal because they seem kind
of strange. These are also incredibly important pointers to God.
And these are going to help lay a foundation so the students can see that God is
present in their everyday lives and things that they just see and interact with on a
daily basis. So for this week, I want you to sort of take a step back and I want to
do some evaluation and I want you to kind of look at some of your
students and take a minute and really try to figure out where some of them are ask
yourself ask yourself a number of questions do a little bit of evaluation to figure
out how you're going to best move forward into this next sort of half of uh of
your of your year so the first thing I want you to really do is spend some time
thinking about where your students are where are they okay
and I don't mean you know they're in youth group or they're not in youth
group, but where are they? If at the very beginning you paid attention to where
they came in and what they were actually thinking about and the questions that they
had. Think about some of the questions that they had, some of the thoughts or
beliefs that they had. Those are all important to figure out
where they are now. Now you may have maybe noted a few students specifically.
I would go back and look at some of those notes and see, has there been any change?
Good or bad, right? Do they have new questions?
Were the questions that they had, have those been answered?
Secondly, do you have any new students?
Now that you've been going for a while, it's kind of easy to get into the
rhythm and forget when new students arrive.
This would be a great time to ask yourself, do you have some of our essentials
materials on hand? See, if I were you, I would always have five or six of our
essentials books on hand ready to go anytime a new student walks in the door to make
sure that they can be brought up to speed pretty quickly and that they don't feel
super intimidated when they're walking the door about in the middle of this crazy
big study that you guys are working on and if you have new students coming in
what are the questions that they have right are they students
who are seeking are these skeptics are they you know your traditional
church students that just find a new church did they move what's going on have some
sort of you know even a matrix to understand where your students are coming from so
that as you move forward you can track this same question for these new students
are there reoccurring questions are there still
questions and my mean by this is are there
the same questions are you not answering questions do we have the
answers yet it's something to consider or are the students just constantly bringing
up the same question I don't mean questions about stuff you're going to get to
because you're going to get to it but questions about anything that's within the
curriculum so far are there reoccurring questions you might want to think about what
you need to do to take some time and maybe pause and actually answer these specific
questions head on find the answers and and get to them so the students can kind of
move on in their minds because a lot of times the students if they get hung up on a
question they have a hard time moving through to the next thing they need those
things answered oftentimes especially some of your brighter students who
just are like super inquisitive and want to know things, if they have a question,
they have to have that answered often.
So you're going to want to stop and get those questions answered.
Which students are tracking?
Now this is sort of something we often forget about
is some of our students track really well.
And it might be easy for you to get hung up on those students that do.
Because those are the students, as you're talking to your group or the people in
your small group that are either, you know, talking a lot, raising their hand, or
they're students that are like super engaged and like really, really paying
attention to you. It's easy to get focused on those students.
It's good to notice it, but don't get overly focused on it because what you're going
to end up doing is you're going to forget that there are students still
that are pushing back.
Are there students pushing
back on you? Is there a student, and I don't mean verbally, I mean the kid in the
back that's doing this, that has that look on their face like, I'm not buying
it. I'm just not buying it.
I would engage that student, not in front of everybody, but after it's all done,
after, after, you know, before, after, whatever, when there's a little more one-on
-one time, is ask that student, like, hey, I noticed you seem kind of questioning.
Do you have a question about what I was saying?
Don't be afraid to engage that student a little bit.
Those are some of the most fun students.
But I'm going to put a caveat on it because there's probably a couple of different
camps depending on where you sit, okay?
Some of you are going to get focused here because you want that like
affirmation that like, hey, everyone's listening to me and this is great and I've
got these students tracking. To be honest, that's sort of my push is I love the
students that really, really get engaged and ask great questions and those kind of
things. Some of you might get like totally, you know, dialed into what these
students are doing and you forget everybody else.
However, some of you might get really dialed in to these students like that's my
project I want I want to get that student I want to do everything I can to make sure
that student before they walk out of here believes in Jesus I'm going to get that
student to accept Jesus and I'm gonna great goal but don't do that
and forget about everybody else it's easy to get you know switched on to one or the
other and then there's everybody else in the middle too you don't want to forget
them either okay but ask yourself where your students are, so you get a pretty good
idea. I'll never forget one particular student that I had years ago in one of
my apologetics class. He sat in the back for probably the entire class,
arms folded, feet up on the desk looking at me like this is the dumbest class
ever. Why am I here? I have to be here.
I can't switch out of this class and I'm stuck.
And I remember every time I just would basically give my lecture or my talk or the
discussion, whatever we were doing for that day, I would like focus it right on him
to make sure that I was talking to him and I would look for little hints, little
just changes in the eyebrow or changes in posture and non-verbals just to see what
he was thinking. And then every day after class as the students were walking out, I
would ask, so how was class today?
Do you have any further questions?
What's going on? How are you?
Or I'd see him in class or in the hallway at a different point in the day, and I
would ask questions to sort of, even if he didn't say anything, just to get non
-verbals out of him to see if I was making progress.
By the end, I never saw him accept Christ, but by the end, he said,
there's something to what you're saying.
That's all I ever got out of him.
And I honestly don't know whatever happened after that.
I just pray that somewhere along the line, he has found Jesus.
But at that moment, that was awesome because I knew I was moving him in the
right direction.
Okay, so that's a whole lot of observations, a whole lot of stuff that you need to
think through.
So now you need to figure out how do you move forward?
How do you go to the next level?
How do you do the next sort of things that we have coming?
Now it might just be keep going and just keep on the next thing, keep on doing the
next thing, and it's no big deal.
But it might be do you put the brakes on someplace do you go back to an old lesson
and revisit something think through don't be afraid to make some adjustments if
that's what you need to do remember there's gonna be ebbs and flows there's gonna be
ups and downs but the goal is to provide our students with what they need to be
prepared to move the gospel forward and to proclaim the kingdom that's the goal